it's not visit to the tower without a  dance party right all right let's be  dancing so thank you so much everyone  for joining us I'd like to thank our  live studio audience please again join  me in thanking subject matter experts  mark Noseworthy Tyson green fellow  community manager Cosmo with your  questions and I'm beach from bungee a  couple of programming notes next week  the conversation about the taken King  continues we're actually going to fire a  few shots in anger at the Cabal we're  going to infiltrate the Dreadnought and  we're going to fight the Cabal in enemy  territory so please join us as we play a  new strike special community guest mr.  fruit will be on hand to lend some of  his covering fire  you